Hawaii, birthplace
of the Kenyan usurper,
is the first state
to challenge the new
and improved Trump travel ban.
My signa... Look, right here.
This is Trump's signature.
"My signature looks
like a fence!"
(laughter)
No one's getting
through that signature.
Lawyers for the state of Hawaii
took a break
from drinking pink drinks
through long straws
on a perfect beach
to ask a federal judge
for a temporary block
on the travel ban,
claiming it would result in
the, quote,
"establishment of religion
in the state of Hawaii
contrary to its state
constitution,"
and would, quote,
"inflict immediate damage
"to Hawaii's economy,
educational institutions,
and tourism industry."
Then they climbed
into their Ferraris
and fishtailed back
to meet Higgins
for poi
at Robin Masters' estate.
-(theme to Magnum, P.I. plays)
-(cheers and applause)
All right, all right,
turn it off. Turn it off.
These millennials can't handle
Magnum. It's too much for 'em.
-(laughter)
-I'm (bleep) kidding.
Play it again! Come on!
-♪ -Yeah.
-(applause and cheering)
All right, turn it off.
Turn it off.
Turn it off. Turn it off.
I'm a white guy.
That's the only time
I get near the word "Magnum."
(laughter and groaning)
Just kind of nice to be near it,
to be honest.
You can tie off the ends, but
it doesn't really do anything.
(laughter)
Comedians, this is, of course,
the Trump administration's
second travel ban.
The first one got struck down
by those pesky judges
and their stupid
separation of powers
and goddamn intimate
understanding
of the legal system and whatnot.
So how do you think
this one will shake out?
How do you think this one
will shake out?
Anyone can buzz in. Pardis.
The first travel ban
affected seven Muslim countries.
People protested.
The government
heard the protests,
and now the ban only affects
six countries.
So, I think
it's gonna go pretty well.
(laughter)
-(applause)
-All right, points.
-Mo.
-That's me.
So, uh, Iraq is off the list,
-but now Hawaii is considered
an enemy combatant. -(laughter)
-That's what's gonna happen.
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Yeah, points.
-We're gonna attack them any day
now, I feel like. -Absolutely.
-Yeah. Fahim.
-I think it's great
what Hawaii is trying to do,
but I don't think
you're getting a lot
of Muslim visitors to Hawaii.
Like, Spam is
their number one food.
-(laughter)
-Yeah.